well Peter it
welcome it's great to have you with us I
love hearing about folks background and
what brings in to doing the things they
they now find exciting you went to
Chicago as an undergraduate and did
mathematics as your major and then went
off to sea immunity to computer science
what what provoked you to to decide
going from math to computer science yeah
it's a good question um at University of
Chicago math was sort of a sort of a
default path for me in some sense I came
in with I had been an advanced program
of mathematics in high school I had a
great fortune of being part of a program
at the University of Buffalo that that
took students in high school through
high school math and then fairly far
into college-level math while still in
high school and so in some sense I did
you know the the math major at Chicago
mainly so I would have lots of time for
electives I've seen in a whole bunch of
other areas but I was you know really
I'd from an early time and I think I
actually may place it to a one of these
sort of career day events where they
brought us from our must have been high
school and maybe it was even middle
school to research labs and at the
University in Buffalo and then you know
introduced you to you know here's what
happens in the chemistry lab here's what
happens in the biology lab and was there
sort of introduced to the idea of how
amazing the things the human brain does
just through it a little exercise where
they just you know told us you know on
this piece of paper identify the the
squares and the and the triangles in the
circles which is you know trivial for up
for us but was sort of at that time
cutting eight edge computer vision and
just really drove home to me how far we
were from being able to understand how
the human brain works and or to be able
to replicate it and so I sort of spent
my college years at Chicago sort of
trying to figure out what was the right
field to get it that question of how
does the brain work how does
intelligence work so I I went to a
neuroscience course and learned how
you know synapses worked and axons and
dendrites and and but nothing close to
you know getting us towards intelligence
and and then I went to some psychology
classes where you know from the other
end saying here's some behaviors here's
some theories and how they work and and
then it was it was in the computer
science classes and there happened to be
at Chicago at the time there were a
bunch of faculty who were former
students of Roger shank at Yale so there
was Chris Hammond Jim Furby and Chris
Owens and I took a series of courses
with them that really sort of inspired
me to think about artificial
intelligence and as and that's where I
sort of got was much more satisfied than
in the neuroscience courses and the
psychology courses that we were really
trying to get at it at the level that I
the that felt visceral to me that I felt
like we were there was progress on
really theorizing about what is
intelligence and then trying to build
artifacts that would they would mimic
that as a way of doing it and so I asked
them you know where where should I if I
want to continue studying artificial
intelligence where should I go and they
pointed me towards Carnegie Mellon and
then I was off to the races that's
interesting and this was a great time
my sense is for when you actually went
out to CMU to do this work it was kind
of the blossoming of an acceptance of
probability theory and an uncertainty
action under uncertainty these were the
kinds of things that I had to I am my
colleagues to the fight force grad
students a few years before when we were
at Stanford and working with other folks
and other grad students in my cohort CMU
and it might see we had kind of a the
rising college of folks interested in
uncertainty but you came into that world
and and did you right away head into
robotics
not right away so my first year I was
working in classical planning in the in
the prodigy system that was jaime
carbonell and his students and then my
adviser Manuela Veloso she did her PhD
thesis in the Prague
so I started off in in classical
planning for the first year and some of
my first papers were published in that
area but it was at my after my first
year of graduate school I went to the
triple AI conference it was actually
here in Seattle
I remember a UI and triple AI that year
word Seattle's I was a fun fun summer
yeah and so one of the one of the
demonstrations they had like you know
demonstration rooms and so there was a
room with a demonstration it was by Alan
Mackworth and one of his students
Michael Shirota from University of
British Columbia and it was a robot
soccer demonstration but it was you know
and it had a ping-pong ball on a
ping-pong table one robot on each team
sort of you know moving around and they
had some research they called it
reactive deliberation so I was sort of
bridging the gap between sort of the the
robotics theory of the day from from rod
Brooks and on you know subsumption
architecture texture and everything
being you know straight from sensor to
action reactivity to you know try to the
more classical planning trying to
deliberate decide what to do but I I had
been at the time I was a and I still am
I was a soccer player I played on my
college varsity team I looked at that
and I said well that looks really
inspiring but it's not really soccer
there's only one robot on each team
that's that's team it's just one-on-one
and so you know and then I thought well
you know and it actually has connections
to what I've been working on planning
but now within a dynamic world and
there's you could be multiple agents on
each team it could really take planning
to the next level and does the story
that I like to tell of my I was really
good friends and still am good friends
with Astro teller who's currently ahead
of X we were both advisees of yes that's
pretty quickly so make sure people hear
that yeah but so Astro and I were Co
advisees of Manuel of great friends and
so I told and we also played soccer
together so I was telling them also
Astro was a bit school with you yes yeah
we were entered Carnegie Mellon in the
same year we shared an office all the
way through grad school and so I and we
played on the same soccer team and so it
I looked at that and said Oh that'll be
a great area to do research on so we
spent like a couple days bouncing ideas
off each other how are we gonna convince
convince Manuela to let me do research
it was for my PhD on robot soccer and so
we came up with all these arguments oh
it's you know related to planning and
this was for you for both of you for
just me and and so he had it all down
and I was ready to go in and just do a
lay it all out here's how I'm gonna
convince you that this is a great domain
for AI and then the next time we saw
Manuela she was coming down the big
escalator in the convention center in
the hotel or wherever the conference was
we were going up and Astrid just showed
it hey Manuela Peter wants to work on
robot soccer and Manuela said okay and
so that was you know after my first year
I then went back and we decided I was
going to I started with the simulator
that Alan and Michael had used at
University of British Columbia and and
then we also said let's actually build
our own physical robots we I didn't know
anything about robotics at the time but
we you know we brought in a mechanical
engineer who you know who built some
robots out of basically a glue gun and
wires he did you know he just got some
wheels and why are these up he was
definitely not an electrical engineer he
was a mechanical engineer um but you
know we got them so that they could you
know they could move and we got a camera
and I started looking at vision
algorithms there's all sort of you know
try I'm trying to get this working from
the perspective of yeah let's you know
this is a great challenge that would
unify planning which is where we were
coming from but also expand towards
robotics multi-agent systems and
unreasoning under uncertainty became a
really big part of that and so you know
machine learning how would you get these
agents or these robots to improve over
time there have to take actions how do
you take actions that's through
reinforcement learning and reinforcement
learning is built on on the reasoning
about uncertainty and so very quickly
it's just sort of natural to me that
this is the way we would go and in the
research and it was I think like you say
it was a time people had already
embraced Bayesian reasoning for you know
for some aspects but I think
reinforcement learning was still you
know learning from about how to act was
still a very nascent area and that was
the fringe that was you know you'd go to
the machine learning conferences and
there'd be like two or three
reinforcement learning papers or maybe
one session and and you know most people
thought of it as sort of the you know
the the crazy that you'd have to
convince people to to work on blood and
to be honest the the the the theoretical
principles around reinforcement was
still evolving at that time well it was
the so the the probably the landmark
that sort of launched reinforcement
learning to into the sort of modern area
era where there was the convergence
proof of q-learning Watkins thesis in 89
and I started my my PhD work in 93 so it
was still young there yeah it was around
but it was young and now people were
really trying to build from that but in
very sort of small theoretically
grounded settings they weren't really
embracing the big problems of trying to
make this work in practice and then not
long after I guess you know that a big
sort of focal point for the community
was when Gerry - sorrow at IBM did neuro
gammon did learning backgammon using cue
learning and so that was sort of a
demonstration that look you can do this
on more than just grid worlds and you
know but still most of the community was
and to some extent still remains very
theoretically oriented which sort of
tied them to smaller problems and I
always wanted to say you know how can we
just you know even if it's not
theoretically guaranteed to work could
we use this in a multi agent set in
setting or in a robotic setting and so
that that's where my focus was so so
Peter what's your your a sense of this
interesting it's not exactly a trade-off
but it may be a choice about
understanding and pursuing deeply but
but in a narrow way technical extensions
where you could really more easily plot
your course theoretically to extend the
theory versus taking some understandings
and jumping into bigger problem domains
where you might have trouble wrapping
one's mind and once there
around the big problems I do imagine you
can these could frame lots of
interesting new questions but what is
your sense about you know when to do
what yeah that's a great question I
think about that a lot I think there's
there's a really important role for both
types of approaches and in fact I insist
on you know PhD students in my lab I
I've had students and I have students
who whose natural tendency is to start
from first principles and to start from
algorithms and and build off and you
know take that next theoretical step for
those students I insist that okay let's
do the you know let's prove what your
new algorithm is or what the new
algorithm is let's develop it but you're
not done until you apply that to
something let's just show us what it's
good for try to bridge that gap to
understanding you know how far can it
get you and then I have students who
really you know they're more engineers
at heart and they say I want to start
with a problem I want to solve that
problem by hook or by crook by hook or
by crook and I tell them look you can
solve that problem but you're not done
until you can now distill away what is
that key algorithmic contribution that
you made and show you know that what's
that nugget that could apply somewhere
else as well right that's not just for
your problem and so I think you know
traditionally when AI started as a field
there was no option you had to sort of
start from the bottom up and work on the
you know the basic principles I feel
lucky that when I came into the field
there were enough tools in the various
different areas there was rudimentary
vision and then natural language
processing and planning and and robotics
that that you could take a problem and
say let me take the best of the
technology that's out there right now
integrate put them all together and
figure out where they're lacking and
where they're lacking is going to be
what motivates the research you know the
research that I'm gonna do like so I
said I'm gonna try to solve the robot
soccer problem okay we're pretty good at
navigation but the you know the vision
is passable but we still don't know what
you know how to make the decisions so
let's let's try to work on reinforcement
learning for that or so it's more like
you know I think it
I would never advocate that everybody
should work in one mode or the other I
think there's great you know productive
room for productivity in either either
realm I think traditionally in the field
the sort of more applications oriented
research has been underrepresented and
so I feel it's been part of my role to
try to evangelize that a little bit that
that it needs to be appreciated that the
challenges of integration it's not just
putting pieces together there's actually
research and how do you put those pieces
together and what problems can we do now
and what do we still need what pieces
are still missing and then trying to
make progress on that but but I don't I
mean that would be a horrible state of
affairs if everybody started doing that
and nobody started trying to you know
kept kept at the you know the the basic
algorithm so I think you know we take
all types and it's a that's what's
exciting about the community and and I
try to make my lab as much as possible
bridge that gap not and make you know
that make sure that every student who
comes out has sort of you know wherever
they started they at least take a step
in the other direction right I think
it's um it's interesting to think I just
look back on problems I've worked on
this idea of starting big sometimes in
new areas defines new interesting
directions that become interesting
pieces of theory if you recall any
particular examples of that yeah I mean
you know I mean in my own in my own
research that is the when I came to try
to do decision making reinforcement
learning for for a robot soccer decision
making there was no really
multi-agent theory of reinforcement
learning there and so I had to introduce
a new you know a new algorithm as part
of my my PhD thesis for multi-agent
reinforcement learning that's sort of
you know I think it wasn't beyond what
people could conceive of but there was
still so many other little you know so
many other problems that people were
working on nobody had gotten there yet
and this was it was an immediate need
for me and so it's it's sort of you know
absolutely at moat I think there's
there's lots of examples of that when
when I've some of my work in the trading
agent competition there we needed to
develop a new I was
with Rob Shapiro and and Michael Kern's
and Satine they're saying Michael
Lippmann back at AT&T and there was a
particular decision making problem that
we needed to address you know that was
because of the rules of that competition
that basically inspired a new extension
of the boosting based algorithm for
logistic regression that was very tied
to some of the research that Rob Shapiro
in particular had been doing at the time
with you or Freud but but was a new
extension that I think you know never
would have thought to to go down if we
hadn't had that need from the actual
domain we were looking and I think it
happens all the time
you mentioned that their work in trading
so how did you get in some ways people
might say okay these are all agents and
decisions under uncertainty but the
trading world is very different in some
ways oshc many ways than their the the
teamwork agents space for a robot soccer
what's the link there in your mind yeah
so I mean this was a time I had finished
my my PhD I was now at AT&T Labs I was
working getting people there involved we
had a dream team of people in
reinforcement learning there was a
really phenomenal environment and I got
them involved in some of the challenges
on a robot soccer but where I was also
looking for some new new direction to go
in and I wanted it still to have to do
with with multi agency and a machine
learning and it so happened that that
Mike Wellman at the University of
Michigan and his group were thinking of
trying to build a competition for
trading agents that was inspired by
Robocop and so I had a conversation with
him he was I didn't even know that yes
so this was like the kind of trading
variant of Robocop yeah very much so and
you know I mean I don't know how they
originally conceived of it but but
certainly he asked me as it's one of the
you know early participants in Robocop
from my experiences on you know how did
what are the what are the the pros and
cons of running a competition what are
some of the pitfalls they should avoid
and so I consulted with them and worked
with them on this on this domain and it
intrigued me because it didn't have many
of the same many of the same properties
and in fact I have an early paper
after having spent the year to doing the
trading agent competition sort of
comparing and contrasting robots ovens
and and trading agents as domains for
artificial intelligence as as
competitions as sort of multi agent
environments and yeah there's there's um
so to me there there is a there's a lot
of connections but you know it is
decision-making reasoning under under
uncertainty and uncertain futures some
of this you know same kinds of
techniques and methods apply but it was
also a way of branching out a little bit
and not you know not just working on
what I had also done and my always done
in my thesis no I call it that you you
were one of the most energetic of the
folks involved in this Asilomar study of
tripoli I did that I put together with
Bart Selman and others back in 2008-2009
and this was all about thinking about
what we were calling then which
resonated deeply with you I would
imagine AI in the open world and
long-term entire futures early on you
one of the folks the heads you know sort
of deep interests and passion in the
implications of these technologies as
they evolved for people in society but
if you have any comments about that in
terms of your involvement in that space
and why that was so important to you
yeah no I do I mean it's you know to me
you know we're dealing and creating a
very powerful technology potentially
very powerful technology and that has
the potential and we're seeing very much
so in these days to really shape and
influence and change society and you
know it's coming from a liberal arts
background and you know I it's it's not
a pure technologist I don't think you
know that we should I think you know
it's not just let's do what we do things
because we can we should also be
thinking about the implications and yeah
the the
you know Asilomar meeting was was
whatever I think may have been one of my
first sort of you know experiences with
with people really thinking about this
and and putting a verbalizing it have
been sort of percolating in my mind a
lot but yeah really valued that you put
that together and and it's led to you
know we as you know we've we've worked
together and I was very honored to be
the first study panel chair for the 100
study were we really you know jumping
ahead several years then I guess almost
a not quite a decade later but you know
and and that now has actually led to a
much bigger effort at the University of
Texas at Austin called good systems a
Grand Challenge project that we've
that's really brought together engineers
and and technologists with people from
the social sciences public policy law
thinking about what actually does it
mean for a technological system to be
good how do you build a good system but
first of all what does it mean to be
good how do you you know evaluate
whether something is good and then how
do you build something that that's good
and I'm one the the organizing committee
of this and it's very explicitly did
come out of the the sort of the study
panel report of the a 100 and one of the
ways I like actually thinking about this
now is that we they're sort of two axes
of I mean you can add many more but the
two actually like to think about it
technology are along one axis how
beneficial it is for society and on the
other axis how accept how easy it is for
society to accept it and I've actually
as you know I've been done research in
self-driving cars on the autonomous
intersection management and things like
that I'm quite convinced that if we that
you know that we could get to a point
very certainly if all the cars on the
road were autonomous but probably even
without that we can get to a point where
there are fewer fatalities if cars were
autonomous yet it's really not clear if
we're ever gonna how long it'll take for
people to accept
regardless of how good they would be
there's this sort of acceptability
barrier and so you know you have things
that could that's just you know a
potential example of something that
could be very good but difficult for
people to accept and then there's other
things like social media that people are
very quick to accept but it's very
debatable whether they're good for
society and really you know what we want
what I want and what you know for as a
technologist is to think about how can
we build things that are both good and
can be accepted and do you mean by
socially acceptable psychologically do
you mean costly to accept height so all
of these things right so like you know
it's it's not just whether something is
technologically possible it's right we
have to have the the social acceptance
we have to have it be cost-effective
there have to be there has to be the
legal framework around it possibly the
insurance framework around it there's
lots of factors that go into determining
whether something will that could have a
lot of beneficial impact actually will
and so you know and that's for a system
to be good it has to actually have an
impact right it's not just you don't
want to just leave it as potential one
of them actually you know one of the
I've always felt it's you know it is a
responsibility especially in AI it's so
you know people come to AI with you know
sort of impressions from science fiction
often and you know so either the the
doomsday you know dystopian view of AI
or the or the more optimistic utopian
view but very you know very rarely the
the the middle road which I think you
know I've always felt is the is the case
that there's you know there's potential
for AI to do good there's potential for
AI to do harm but it's not going to just
happen we have to be thinking about how
to how to to make this you know these
worlds come about and so for many years
I've given in in my talks I've asked in
my especially outreach talks I've asked
people to engage in discussion about
just the general trends of technology
our technology making the world a better
place or as technology making them
better the world a worse place and so
the way I ask that question often is I
say you know if you had a choice of
being born either a hundred years later
than you were born or a hundred years
earlier than you were born which would
you choose now in a room can I can I get
a Geiger counter reading yeah so that's
that's one of the questions right it's
there's a leap of faith to believe too
going ahead hundred years will the world
still exist will there have been a
nuclear disaster and anyway in a room of
computer scientists still even with that
almost everybody says I'd like to jump
forward but if you engage in this
conversation with people from across you
know a university and talk with people
in the social sciences and you'll get
some pretty passion and and arguments
that you know first of all there's a lot
of uncertainty in you know there's a
leap of faith that you know the world
may not exist a hundred years later from
when you were born but also you know
some some very real senses in which they
feel like the technology is is
decreasing quality of life and I think
it's you know it's it's important as
people who are causing these changes to
grapple with these issues and they have
answers for them and if you think you
know I wouldn't be doing what I'm doing
if I didn't believe that the technology
and AI technology in particular is
making the world a better place but it's
not a given just because we can do
things doesn't mean we should and of
course there are different hands these
technologies can fall in and there's the
losses that might come of their desires
and goals of the owners of the
technology someday if you if you think
back to again your own career your your
mentoring of many many fabulous students
over the years several we met today at
Microsoft Research Center Microsoft Corp
what kind of advice do you have to just
somebody who's middle of undergraduate
years getting excited about maybe
engineering mathematics or even liberal
arts more generally about how to choose
a career how to navigate for one's
interests in one sense for things yeah
it's a it's a great question people get
that all the time I happen to have
children at about that age so I give
this advice does not always get listened
to of course but you know I think number
one I mean it's cliche but follow your
passion do you know you're you you're
going to be spending a lot of time
working on you know on what you're
working on whether you do a PhD whether
it's your career a large fraction of our
the hours of our lifetime are spent at
work and so you you know the most
important thing is to work on something
you enjoy doing that you care you know
that you care about in terms of you know
I actually think you know like as we
talked about earlier I think when I was
an undergrad it was too early to get
into neuroscience I think there was you
know the level of understanding was at a
level far below what I was wanted to be
able to study intelligence I think
there's just from the perspective of
what drives me into getting into AI I
think there's a lot of exciting
developments coming down the road in
neuroscience computational neuroscience
and and so you know for somebody with
that kind of inclination I say give that
a shot I used to say that you know when
I when I took my first neurosciences
courses I'd say if we ever got to the
point where somebody could tell me
physically what changes in my brain when
somebody tells me their phone number and
I remember it like what are the you know
what's the mechanism that then I would
drop the AI and move to neuroscience and
I think but nobody nobody's been able to
tell me that yet now you sort of know
the secret reason why I have this
mysterious MD degree next yeah might I'd
like my PhD yeah what can I go back put
my lab coat on and exactly get into the
into the neuro I think I think it's a
great it's the time is getting closer
and closer I think there's there's a lot
of you know we're getting close and it's
it's exciting to see people young young
researchers coming out who have a foot
in computer science and in neuroscience
and they're sort of you know starting to
to bridge that gap so that you know
that's one thing the other advice I
think is really sage for young people
coming up is you know to be an expert in
one thing there's always going to be a
lot of people but if you can be an
expert in two things
and and merge them so like you said
having an MD next to your name and and
but uh that's there for that moment when
I go back to the into the lab yeah but I
mean even so I think you know having
being able to bridge disciplines is I
think very valuable and is less it's
always gonna be a less crowded area than
being an expert in one thing so being
you know being able to have a grounding
from you know for for me I like that my
degree was in mathematics and I ended up
in computer science I I started off in
planning but then move to robotics and
having these sort of expertise in
multiple areas very just oh yeah you
know in any one area you're sort of
trying to make a name for yourself in a
crowd but when you're the person in that
area who has an expertise from that
other area you're there's much more
space and and and room to to grow and
contribute and make a name for yourself
as long as that's compatible with what
your passions are I think that you know
there's there's a lot of a lot of
potential benefit for a young person to
be able to to think about what's the new
perspective they can bring to the area
that that said they're most interested
in given everything that you've been
looking at studying against the
background persistent question about
what's going on with human brain do you
feel like you and this is the
cocktail-hour part of our discussion do
you feel like you have any new
intuitions or is a still complete
mystery about how on earth these tangles
of neurons do their thing to give us
these abilities and in this sense of
even being yeah I'm not gonna claim to
be able I've done some fascinating
collaborative research with
neuroscientists and worked in fact one
of the my former students who's now here
at Microsoft Matthew house connect and I
did some joint work with with Professor
in the neuroscience department Mike Mach
who has a wonderful simulator of the
cerebellum and is one of the world's
experts on how the cerebellum works
which is the part of the brain that that
does the kinds of things that
reinforcement learning algorithms do
sort of does some fine motor control
kinds of things so we did some some
great collaborative research
him but really he's you know he was the
neuroscience expert and and i am you
know i i'm fascinated by by by
neuroscience but i can't claim to be
making my own contributions there let me
ask you maybe something a little bit
nearer in than just haven't you try to
feel the question about what's going on
in the brain but speaking of neurons and
and and nets of neurons getting into the
computational variant of what we call
neural net models we've seen the rise
and fall and the rise again there in a
sense of these methods and i was great
to see how you're using some of these
methods like adversarial approaches to
understand reinforcement learning and
learning by watching kinds of scenarios
I'm curious what your sentences for how
these technologies are not fitting in to
the maybe earlier the planning research
we may call it classical planning and
agents research yeah so I've always
taken a very sort of big-tent view of AI
and in fact you know I did start my
first year as a graduate student I was
working in classical planning but then
when I moved to robot soccer the first
learning algorithm I used was a neural
network neural network and I used
decision trees and I use reinforcement
learning programming by owner I think I
said pride programming my own and then I
think I used a package from Andrew
Moore's lab that they had they had built
that for themselves so but it was you
know for it for a specific sub-problem
of robot soccer was trying to get an
agent to figure out when it where it
should move to try to intercept the ball
but and actually as my my undergraduate
research project at University of
Chicago was was in the applied math
department on implementing a neural
network so I've actually been you know a
fan of neural networks from from the
beginning but not as the exclusive role
and you know kudos to the folks who've
really been you know pushing pushing
that approach even when there were you
know people who were who were
pooh-poohing it and saying oh that's not
gonna get us anywhere you know I've
always been been you know sort of
hopeful that that they would be of
practical use and like I said if you
them I think the pendulum may be
swinging too far though in the sense
that's you know the the stories that
these people tell her that oh isn't it
great that well the whole rest of the
field was working on other stuff we work
the kept the torch alive and kept neural
networks going and now they work and so
everybody should do neural networks and
we shouldn't keep any other torques
alive and I think that's going way too
far I think I think you know neural
networks are fabulous there's there's
been some great you know really
surprising results and capabilities from
them but they're not gonna do everything
I don't think this is debatable and
people will you know debate me on this
but I think we're a far cry at least
from them being able to solve the entire
intelligence problem I think there are
an important a very important tool in
the toolbox but I think for the kinds of
problems I'm interested in at least in
the foreseeable future we're gonna need
to bring to bear lots of different ai ai
tools from the from the toolbox and that
includes symbolic and classical
reasoning and then that there's a nice
thriving community that in some sense is
now the analog of the of the neural
network community that's sort of
struggling to keep a voice and be
appreciated I think there's you know
they'll be the day and the Sun again for
this community and of course
probabilistic reasoning and Bayesian
reasoning I think is is you know
something that that these are you know
are never gonna go away I think what we
need to be doing is is understanding
more about the the strengths and
limitations of each of these approaches
and how to put them together into you
know into functioning systems and you
know I I think it's great that there are
some people who want to push neural
networks as far as they possibly can go
and and try to understand what can we do
with with end to end they're all
networks but i but I resist if the claim
starts being and that's the only thing
the entire community should be doing
because I think that's that's going way
too far I think we need to you know like
I said the big tent view of AI I think
there's room for lots of different
approaches and to understand what the
strengths and limitations of all of them
are so Peter you said that by the year
that a we can build a team of humanoid
robots that can beat the best World Cup
champion at soccer on a real soccer
field I should say this was originally
I'm not saying it's not a prediction
it's a it's a goal information
aspiration and it was originally put put
out there by Hiroaki kitano okay so so
so rocky kitano a good friend of both of
ours
put that challenge out there what do you
think of it that that aspiration I think
it's a fantastic aspiration the
fantastic motivating goals and when I
put it in sort of context with and and
I'm comfortable saying even the same
breath as a challenge of landing a man
on the moon the you know the Apollo
mission and the challenge of sequencing
the whole human genome both of which
have achieved their you know their goals
that we're sort of you know big
scientific efforts that's especially
landing a man on the moon was not
necessarily in and of itself of
practical importance but to get there it
was gonna have to drive technology and
engineering in new directions and I see
that's you know this this robot soccer
challenge is serving that role it's it's
a very easy to state ambition it's very
inspiring to people worldwide it drives
a lot of different needs from a from an
AI and robotics and technological
development perspective and it really
you know takes to the next level things
like chess and go and jeopardy which are
you know to where and poker where
there's you know in some cases complete
information some cases incomplete
information but are not about physical
interaction in the world as much as
about you know pure you know AI
knowledge kinds of systems this we often
like we do at the time when kitano put
this this out it was in 1996 or 1997 it
was right around the time of deep blue
in the and Gary Kasparov and deep blue
winning that match and so we you know we
say what are the differences between
soccer and chess chess you have you know
discrete
you can represent the state as being
discrete in soccer it's continuous you
have full information versus you know
partial information because you only see
in one direction and and you ask you
know a single ability of success by then
you know I really go for it I just can't
either way I don't want to down to a
number here I think you know it's the
the intelligence side of it I can get a
handle around the physical aspect of can
you build robots that are as agile and
as people AI that is much more difficult
for me to imagine but when I look back
20 years to the you know compared to the
robots that are possible these days
there's been huge advances so I you know
I I wouldn't bet on it and I wouldn't
bet against know that that's a fine
answer I want and push you too hard on
that so so what are the key challenges
we need to solve between now and when
that does happen yeah I think there's
generally just you know there's there's
two classes of challenges there's the
physical you know the physical hardware
can you get a robot that can run and
change directions and and and manipulate
a ball and and you know and and then
there's the cognition that this sort of
the sense decide and act aspect of VO of
autonomous agents and you know there and
then they have to come together right
what kind of sense decide knack depends
on how the hardware is going I mean it's
it's it always has to be integrated but
there's those challenges I mean in all
of these aspects they're still you know
perception still has to get better I
mean it's your perception is great these
days there's been huge advances but
still not at the level of human
perception and awareness of you know
just put a robot on an outdoor field
with with people moving around at full
speed and the ball like it's you're
still from that egocentric view it's not
gonna still not at the level of people
certainly the actuation there's still
challenges on teamwork I mean really
there's so many different pieces that
have to come together it's that's what
that's what makes it fascinating you
have chance
you know you did so much great work on
teamwork going from single agents to
multi agents and then teams to think
more about what makes good teams in life
with other humans for example yeah and
you know at first I sort of kept to just
autonomous agents and you know people
are people are a pain people are
difficult to work with and then very
unpredictable but now we're moving into
social robots and social robotics and
service robots and that you know the
goal there is is to just have your
robots become a part of society part of
the fabric of a building and that they
can do the things that not to be
indistinguishable from people to be but
to be compatible with with people and
that's a very you know that's a social
that's a teamwork kind of endeavor and
and so one of the topics I've worked on
and introduced in multi-agent systems is
what we call ad-hoc teamwork the ability
of an agent to be able to work with
teammates it's never worked with before
at first I thought of that is just all
robot teammates but but really to be a
good team player means also being able
to deal with human teammates and and so
yeah we're thinking a lot now about
about how do you predict what people are
gonna do and respond appropriately how
do we actually influence how people are
gonna interact with you as an agent as a
robot and um
so an example that we just that we just
published in the in the in Roman and the
one of the conferences on human robot
interaction it turns out that if a
robots coming down the hall towards a
person people in North America will
typically move to their to the right
that's what they expect the robot to do
as well and we wanted to see could we do
something to get people to move to the
left and and so our hypothesis was that
we would just flash a blinker and that
people you know on the left and people
would interpret that as a turn signal
and that they would go to the you know
and they would go to the left turns out
half the people did but the other half
thought of it is a directional signal
saying that's where you should go and so
that didn't work but then we took the
next step of doing an active
demonstration of having the robot come
down the hall and when it sees the
person put on its right blinker and move
to the
right to teach the person in one shot
that that's what the blinker means and
then with almost without fail when it
got to the person and turned on the left
blinker the person knew what it meant it
would go the you know go to the left and
so these kinds of this is a part of
being a teammate is being able to reason
about what information do I need to
communicate to this compatriot to this
to this teammate and how do I do it so
that I'll be you know I'll be able to
not only predict what they'll do but
influence what they'll do and I think
that there's really fascinating research
to be done in that space and for all we
know there's a goldmine of research that
sort of be done about people working
together already it's interesting
yeah actually but one of my I should say
I mean I've had the great honor of on my
thesis committee as a PhD student herb
Simon was one of the the members and I
would go into his office and he has a
great body of research on organizational
theory and so he always wanted to bring
in the connections of multi-agent
systems to organizational theory in
businesses and then you know thought and
helped me really think even back then in
the 90s of how you know this emerging
field of multi-agent systems was
connected to this you know area of human
human organizations and teamwork so yeah
it's always been there sort of thanks to
him in the back of my mind it's
fascinating and it would have been
opportunity to have worked with him
directly I love you Herbert Simon as a
meta mentor and that I would see him at
meetings and conferences and through
Fred through through mentors meet him
and talk and great to have had to have
had him on your thesis committee yeah he
was he was fabulous fantastic and he was
a just a huge inspiration to all of us
at around around Carnegie Mellon at the
time I was I was unfortunate to have
arrived just a year or two after Alan
Newell passed away I heard great things
about him and he was also his influence
lived on and and was was a big part of
the culture at Carnegie Mellon but I was
very fortunate that the herb was still
around and to be able to just you know
go into his office and and and talk talk
about talk about research he was just
always um we'd always come up with with
fascinating new ideas he was he was
fantastic
yes that a great set of heuristics I
remember a bunch of them he would just
tell me these mottos like we will be
talking about something and he would say
you really should go home tonight and
write that up tonight the idea of just
getting it done now yeah I love that we
can all use a little bit of that yeah
can you say just a few words about about
what it took to stand up RoboCup yeah
and that's a that's a great question I
first of all I should say I was you know
I was a fortune it's a graduate student
at the time that Robocop got started to
be and I was one of the first people
doing research on it in outside of Japan
but really you know the the vision and
credit for it goes goes to I mentioned
already Hiroaki kitano and Manohar asada
and and its key noticed and then the
other folks in Japan also my adviser
Manuela Veloso got got involved through
the research I was doing with her and
became a really sort of influential a
part of the growing the organization if
it worked people that don't know how it
works so the competitions yeah so so
RoboCup is is it's a it's actually a
very interesting fascinating
organization by itself and I just became
president of it there's there is a board
of trustees that sort of you know you
imagine what they do deal dealing with
we know where the next competition will
be in some of the financial aspects but
then there's also it's divided into
different leagues each of which has
different characteristics so within the
robot soccer realm there's a standard
platform League for an example where
everybody has exactly the same robots
but then they have to program them
differently and then there's a a wheeled
league where people have to build the
robots but they can have wheels and move
around on with a with a golf ball or
then a bigger size league where the use
of real soccer ball then there's a
humanoid League where you build your own
robots but they have to have two legs
and and then there's other other leagues
for disaster rescue and RoboCup at home
and Robocop junior each of these has
representatives on an executive
committee that sort of ties all of them
together to make sure that we're sort of
pushing the scientific
actions agenda in the right direction
each of the league's has a technical
committee that decides on sort of what
will be the roadmap for the rules over
the next you know 10 years or so an
organizing committee that runs the
competition for that particular year and
then there's you know there's a one
international event where everybody
comes together every year but then
there's also regional events that people
you know that have people who are you
know don't want to travel all you can't
take everybody to the international
events so you have you know there's a
China Open and an Iran open and the
European open and the US Open and and it
really it's just a really thriving
beautiful community of people scientists
who are unified by a sort of grand
challenge goals research objectives with
this sort of forcing event or the
focusing event of we have to make
everything work by this deadline every
year and and then we can go away and and
you know and then think about the next
advance that inspired by what the others
did but it's a it's a really thriving
and and beautiful community that really
you can only get a real deep
appreciation for it by coming and and
experiencing the competition firsthand
so actually one of the things I first
did as president was institute a one of
several different policies to try to
bring people who haven't been to RoboCup
so I don't know when you were bent
lasted RoboCup but you should really
come and see it if you haven't recently
but it's yeah I mean it's it's it's the
the events themselves in how many folks
come usually two to three thousand
amazing that are in the participants
across the different leagues and
including RoboCup jr. and others
spectators do come depending on where it
was the biggest one we went it was in
Japan there we did it in the big
baseball state stadium one year and
there were like people snaked around the
entire you know Stadium trying to get in
and in the bleachers more typically it's
open to spectators but it's you know
it's a science event we don't make it an
entertainment event so there's been some
some very I think important decisions
that have been made
it's not as it's not primarily a
spectator sport it's primarily a
scientific initiative fantastic to bring
school groups through and teach them
about science but it's not curated in a
way that you know would make for a good
you know TV show or you know that's just
not been the focus of the community and
another really important decision in my
opinion has been there it's not about
prize money right so you get these
competitions like the urban challenge
and things like that
where it's about you know you'll win
several million dollars if you're the
one who wins the competition there's no
prize money in robocop that the the the
goal is to you know or the benefit of
winning the competition is basically the
ability to disseminate what you've done
to inspire other people it's it's much
more you know what what academia is all
about and so you get people winning and
releasing their source code and writing
papers about it and sharing and then
people building on it the next year and
and improving as a community and I think
that's that's been a really important
important aspect of it so Peter I'm
gonna make a commitment to check back
with you personally 20 in 2050 it till
December ok 31st to see where we are
with RoboCup and the humanoid robots but
more about our understanding of the
brain in a more generally so thanks very
much for being here today my pleasure
thanks for inviting me